[Music]
thing would be in let's hold back you
know we'll start every episode like that
everybody riffing with Griffin fun so
here we are thanks for coming out
thanks for uh you know being a part of
this but I'm here I'm here in Chicago
and you know what I said enough talk I'm
on iTunes I'm on stitcher I'm on every
place I need to be so I said let's do
episode 1 you know I mean that's just -
episode 1 and Here I am so I got a
little GoPro set up you know it's not
the best situation so please stop
trippin when you watch my damn thing I'm
gum but by the time I get to episode 100
let's hope I get to a hundred hopefully
by then it's gonna be like it's gonna be
all fancy you know what I mean
it's gonna be ring girls or I don't know
but anyway I thought episode one of
riffing we're girlfriends should be
about me you know who am i right what's
my story you know if you've ever
wondered what my story is well I'm here
to tell it to you right now so um let's
see
when I was you know I'm in the business
right I'm in the comedy business I've
always wanted to be a comedian I think
I've always wanted to be a comedian my
mom told me when I was a kid that I said
I wanted to be a comedian and Here I am
I mean my biggest influence was watching
Eddie Murphy like not even just Eddie
Murphy but like like Eddie Murphy all
the things that he did like being on SNL
when he was like Gumby oh man he
buckwheat he was like that should have
been called the Eddie Murphy show back
in the day so that was like my huge
influence to want to be funny right and
then delirious came out and delirious it
was funny like it was I've never seen
anything like that before like
black man you know like an Allred
leather suit at Carnegie Hall or
wherever he was I think was at Carnegie
Hall he was just doing his thing and it
was like wow but stand up wise it
actually wasn't till raw it was until I
saw raw in the movie theater and I was
like damn this is crazy
like I want to do that and so I don't
even know where to even begin it was
like it was like I was in my early 20s
and I took I told my mom I was like
y'all want to be stand-up comedian and
she was like what my mom wanted me to be
something completely different
you know she was like okay but my mom's
really supportive so she's like one of
these types that if I tell I want to do
something she's gonna find a class so
she found a UCLA extension class at the
you know UCLA in Westwood campus the
main campus so it was like a Tuesday
night and I go to this stand-up comedy
class and he was being taught by sandy
shore r.i.p she just recently died so
god rest her soul but she was my first
stand-up teacher and it was like such a
weird experience you know and then like
her mom was Mitzi shore god rest her
soul - everybody's dying in the shore
family so at the time I thought oh yeah
this is gonna be my in at the Comedy
Store cuz you heard about the
world-famous Comedy Store but anyway you
did this class and I all I recommend
anyone that wants to try to do stand-up
to take one class just one class take a
class so you could feel comfortable so
you kid like be in that environment and
you'll be like oh this is great you know
you you're gonna be comfortable with
these other people who are in your
position people that don't know how to
do it yet are nervous or scared so it's
a real supportive comfortable
environment and I suggest you do that if
you want to be a stand-up I mean that's
what I did and I think it's I think it's
very helpful you know
I stayed in classes way too long because
I didn't know what I was scared and
that's desta honest answer I was afraid
I didn't think I could do it it was a
pipe dream so I went to to class you
know finished a class and we had a
showcase at the Comedy Store which was
great I don't even
how important that was at the time like
right now if I hear about a class and
they're performing at the comedy store
I'd be like whoa you guys don't even
know what you're this is too much for
y'all but I did it you know I had this
real fun set I remember I had like
really dumb hacky jokes not like my
current dumb hacky jokes but yeah I
remember like one of my jokes was like
like black people on Jeopardy and I had
like Jeopardy categories like BBQ
holidays blind singers stupid
I remember my big joke was about
Superman Chee I was like how come people
don't know Superman at Clark Kent then I
would stand here not be like this let me
show you the difference Clark Kent
Superman Clark Kent Superman you know I
thought I was hilarious but it went well
I'll tell you something I regret it I
didn't invite my mom to my first show I
didn't want her to see me I was nervous
I was scared I'm wondering I didn't want
to fail in front of her I didn't want
her to like think I wasn't funny you
know I let my stepdad calm but I didn't
let her come and I regret that I really
do regret that I wish she would have
seen my first performance you know so I
did that and then I went to and then I
went then I did like a comedy acting
class and she came to the showcase of
that and that was the first time I saw
on her face that she was like oh I think
you can really do this so I changed her
mind about what she want me to do but
excuse me at the time I was like
20-something years old I didn't know
what [ __ ] I was doing once I finished
doing the first set I was like what'd he
do now and then it was like oh you got
to go to open mikes
are you to build up a reputation oh you
have to like get to know people you have
to cultivate your your your act and like
find your point of view no one told me
any of that [ __ ] so I was like I don't
know what I was doing man no mentors
nobody was trying to help you the open
mics were weird it was like heavy
hitters at these open minds I remember
going to open mic with Jim Gaffigan and
Jamie Kennedy in like it was it was like
I anyways I stopped you know I had a
really bad experience at a club where
like I just bombed so
bad and the MC was clowning me and I
just was like you want talking about
bully Comedy the comics can be bullies
you know J Anthony Brown you're a bully
he's the one made me feel so bad but you
know I didn't I stopped doing it cuz I
wasn't even really doing it I was gonna
open mics like rarely you know so I
would go to open mic and then I would be
arrogant I was young and arrogant I was
like oh these people still here doing
the same thing how do I get out of here
I want to get on the real stages I mean
that's how you think when you're young
you think that you entitled to be at
places that people earned and work for
and that's still a problem today there's
still people today to think that they
deserve to go up you know places are can
skip the steps it's necessary to get to
where you need to get so you don't do
that don't skip steps so cut to later in
life I decide you know I I don't want to
like I don't want to like have regrets
so I started going to open mics and then
I was going by myself because my friend
like pushed me towards him my buddy Jeff
you know he was like you know don't do
it on your own cuz at the time that it
was a crutch it's a crutch if you have
someone that you go to open mics with
all the time you think did that makes
you comfortable it's cool to go with
them occasionally but don't make it
where you can only go to the open mic
with that person so you young comics out
there if you listen and don't have your
people you go with you have a core group
but you got to be able to go on your own
sometimes you got to be like yo you go
to that one I love this one I'll meet
you at the other one but you got to do
it on your own it's a solo venture it
really is you have a community of
support your peer group of support but
it's a solo venture so make sure you get
out there on your own so that's what he
did he my buddy was like I don't want to
go if you want to be a comic you be a
comic yelled at me and I was like damn
and that was the first time the next day
I went to an open mic by myself and it
changed my life because then I was like
oh wow I don't gotta wait for anybody I
went to another spot and then I just
started building up for like a year or
two you know that was like in 2003 and
then I finally got like you know I
finally started getting sponsors people
started to respect me a little bit and
then you know 2004 I had my first
out-of-town Road gigs I went to Montana
and I did those Tribble runs you know so
I was driving all around Montana
with another comic I did like many of
those runs and then I went I was the
feature that I started headlining those
runs you had to do an hour like a power
I'm in my first hour was in Butte
Montana and I was like I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm gonna talk about for an
hour [ __ ] was crazy but I did it
you know and then 2005 I got into the
Seattle comedy competition that's where
I met some of my best friends some my
friends today you know my buddy David
Meza dickey-fuller on that God rest his
soul he died this year am all people
nine it was fun Andy King Andy no it's
not Andy King what's Andy's last name I
know so many Andy's but it wasn't Andy I
did know actually I did you know what my
first contest was the Rocky Mountain
laughs off that's where I met people I
went to Utah I did the Rocky Mountain
laughs off and I feel like I got robbed
I came in second place and I met this
comic I remember I met this comic from
st. Louis and he was hating on me man he
was just like are you a hack he wasn't
you know going on because I came in
second and then and you tall you have to
be relatively clean because of the
Mormons so I was doing good I was in
first place and then there was a night
where they said okay you could be dirty
tonight this is the one night you could
be dirty well I went for it
and then I came in last place that night
and I was like I said I've messed me all
up so I ended up coming in a second in
the whole thing and then I did the Rocky
Mountain then I did the Seattle
competition and that was like grueling
competitions are grueling you know I
just don't like what they do to you
mentally they train you for like if you
want to be like to audition they train
you for that they train you that
five-minute sets like if you have to go
on like audition for a late-night are
you there's some like comedy show with
ten comics and you have to like know how
to do a quick five-minute set
competitions are the best for that so I
did that you know I did that
you know Seattle Comedy Competition and
it was I hated it I came in like six I
got robbed in a - by the way and there's
a theme forming here right so then I did
another contest where I got to open for
Dave Attell the winner got to open for
Dave Attell you know so that was pretty
cool
so I won that actually and so I'm
opening for Dave Attell and so that was
like then it was like okay then I
started doing things you know 2006 I got
on the payaso comedy slam my buddy
Darren Carter the party starter shoutout
to Darren he told me he asked me to go
with him to this real shitty like room
in like Hawthorne or something like it
was like ghetto as hell like somebody
had been shot there two year before or
something like you know it was like one
of those kind of places were somebody
and so they were having this like weird
Latino night and you know he asked me to
come with him because it was like we had
to get it we had to leave it like five
or six something like that I know Darren
only asked me to go because he wanted to
get in the carpool lane he'll never
admit that but I know that's what it was
because he was even talking about it
so we get there I got a spot and then
Alex Reymundo
one of the Latin Kings of Comedy he was
going up after me he watched me cuz
that's the only reason why comics would
watch each other's if you're going back
to the person because we're not that
supportive and we mother you need to be
more supportive
you know I'm even talking to my current
friends you know but anyway then he said
hey man I'm about to be a part of this
show called the payaso comedy slam I
think you should audition for it
someone's an improv audition I booked it
and it was great that was that was a fun
time it was me Alex George Perez Johnny
Sanchez Edwin San Juan Joey Medina
that's a mall ready but it was just a
bunch of like and it was it was so fun
Rick Ramos it was real fun to tape a
show we did we did it right to at the
time I thought this was the way you
supposed to do we did two shows I don't
San Bernadino Jeff Garcia was also on
the show and it was just like it was
jam-packed and it was like so fun and
like that was my first TV credit and it
was on Showtime so nobody saw it and
then in 2008 I got new faces and I got
live at Gotham so I did live at Gotham
and that I also met my manager I'd met
my manager he wasn't my manager yet but
I met him at new faces because I had a
manager excuse me I had a manager at the
time who shall renamed
remain nameless you know he's [ __ ] huh
look out for who who you have as a
manager but anyway
so I met my current manager eat I eat I
he was a a Junt agent at the time I met
him at new phases we bonded over the
Clippers we just had to bar talking
about the Clippers and it was great he
knew who I was I didn't even know who he
was you know and we we didn't meet -
like a year later a year later when he
was a manager and he was like oh I'm a
manager now you know signed up and been
with him ever since since 2008 so I got
new faces that year and I got live at
Gotham that year and that's when I met
my first agent my first agent TJ mark
Walter you know I love TJ you know you
know he turned he made me an instant
headliner you know wasn't making a lot
of money but he got me out there so I'll
always remember that and respect him for
that so then I started that's when I
started doing it like so 2008 I started
going out on the road so I was like
doing it you know live--i gotham came
out I did new faces so I met people and
want you all and all that and then 2009
ish end of 2009 I auditioned for a
workaholics and then you know I remember
I got the audition and I went there and
I saw Johnny Sanchez there it was like
Johnny Sanchez a few other people that I
knew at this audition and I was like I'm
not gonna get this and then I read it
and I was like it was fun like that was
a fun ass audition the words if you're a
workaholics fan my audition was ain't no
rules in my bedroom there's only one
rule in my bedroom
[ __ ] all rules so that was that whole it
was a whole big monologue you know they
cut it out of the show actually they bet
actually shrunk it way down for the show
cuz they were like oh we gotta make sure
the boys are funny
they were never funnier than me just FYI
Adam Blake on ders you know y'all know
you know but anyway that was a fun
audition I wanted that part my boy Jeff
I was telling you guys about earlier he
helped me with that audition I worked on
it like I was going out for The
Godfather
and it was great I had so I did the
first audition right and I nailed that
[ __ ] I know I did because I remember the
casting director looking at her a
partner she was like okay and they
didn't know what they wanted at the time
either for workaholics they didn't know
what they wanted they didn't know if
they wanted somebody black like
traditional like dark skinned black they
don't they didn't know if they wanted
somebody Latino because it was all kinds
of people in here so anyway I get the
callback so I go to the callback when I
walk into the callback I see like Jay
Phillips I see the dude from the Lopez
show I see this other do from Boston
Legal at the time there was like all
these like experienced actors in the
room and I was like I'm not gonna get
this what am I doing here these people
have been working I was like I'm not
gonna get this but I was like [ __ ] it
I'm gonna do the best I can so I go in
the room and then like Adams in there
and I didn't even know Adam this was his
show I had no idea that this was his
show I just saw him at the brain improv
like a week earlier and I was giving him
like older comic advice like you know
keep doing keep doing what you do
youngster you gonna be all right and he
he sold a show and I'm acting like I'm
giving him advice so it was crazy so I
did that audition and oh I have fun in
that
you know I nailed it I know I knew that
cuz Adam was texting one of my other
buddies like yo your boy killed it but
then I had to audition like three more
times so the first time auditioned they
were like that was good but you were too
big the next time I go in the director
Kyle he's like what happened I was like
y'all told me I was too big so what do
you want you know so then I had to do it
again then it was like wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you know
and then I I booked a part and I
remember I was in El Paso Texas actually
the last time I've been to that cub the
comic strip in El Paso and I remember
Steve Simone was featuring from me at
the time and he shouldn't be featured
but he just wanted to travel with me and
make some money it was like we're
buddies so that's why he came that guy's
a monster Steve Simone's a monster and
so we're just there we were in the car
together and I got to call from etai my
manager he was like you booked apart
like four out of ten you know and I was
like oh and then I walked into the comic
strip thinking to myself well this is
the last time I'm walking into this
building at this rate needless to say I
haven't met
since it's been over ten years since
I've been to El Paso comic strip
I loved it was a cool room I like I like
the guy but he just he don't want to pay
so bye see ya I don't care so I booked
of Alcoholics that didn't air till like
2010 ish I think it was then that aired
and then basically that changed my life
I mean Montes changed my life you know
and then and then not only was I on
workaholics workaholics was like it's
like people's favorite show you know
what I mean it's like there's people out
there that see me and they're like oh my
god I love those showed even if
specially the heyday of it like in the
middle of it people were like oh man
this is me and my friends and then they
think a lot they think it's real they
think it's a documentary you know
they're coming at me with the lines like
why you sell them a broke-ass hovercraft
Montez you know so that people always
ask me do you get annoyed by it and I'm
gonna be lying if I said it wasn't
annoying sometimes but at the same time
as annoying as it can be it also makes
there's a place in my heart that I'm
like damn they really responded to me
like people remember me for what I did
so I have to love it at the same time
you know and I'm and I'm famous enough
where it's like 1 out of 50 people are
like oh can I take a picture or act
crazy so I'm fine with that
like sometimes people act like people
really they act up like I remember us at
this casino gig and I'm walking it's
late at night you know when this dudes
like yo man oh it's Montez what's up and
I'm like hey man how you doing you know
you know then he just keeps going he's
yelling like yo y'all guess what miss
Montez right here yo Montez he's
circling me and yelling with his friends
Montez and I go hey man thank you but
I'm just trying to walk here let's do
girls like this you want ain't that
famous I swear to God I wanted to punch
him in his [ __ ] face you wait dad
that's what people want to do they want
to build you up and tear you to [ __ ]
down you know that's why I hate on
Instagram you know you're on Instagram
and you like you know I like to I follow
people not because I want to follow him
but I follow him because I have OCD
about their private profile so if you
send me a private profile I want to see
the [ __ ] this is so I'm like oh I'll
stand there like who is this you know I
know it's just my weird thing and then
like people will like just recently I
follow somebody and this girl's all like
puts up a post like oh should I say yes
to this and I was like oh my god like
people are like hey good to see you
but anyway so Montez changed my life
name from getting on workaholics I got
on blunt talk with Patrick Stewart yeah
I was great it was fun to just being on
a screen with Patrick Stewart man that
was so fun we had all my lines most of
my lines were with him especially in
season 2 that was so fun you know I wish
that she would have kept going but it
was stars and it's just they didn't know
what the [ __ ] they were doing I'm just
gonna be real they this is I think it
was the first time they did like a
comedy like this they put it on on a
Saturday at 8 o'clock it's like do you
want people to watch this I don't
understand what these networks are doing
but anyway so that so I did that for two
seasons and then at the same time I got
on I'm dying up here and that was great
I've told this story before I just was
at The Comedy Store one night and the
manager Adam egit he's like yo man Jim
Carrey's here and I was like is he
bumping me like I was so mad cuz I was
like yo dude this is our time you made
it already [ __ ] out of here you know I
mean I don't know why I got so mad
that's just my natural thing is to go to
the negative first and I'm trying to
work on that actually and I won't be
talking about this and future podcasts
about communication and attitude and
stuff because you got to change it if
you really want to make it I feel like I
could've gone could have gone further
but I use negativity as like motivation
and I gotta stop doing that you know
it's like it's like okay against me I've
done that my whole life when I was
playing basketball I did that I was I
was that way when I was in high school I
always felt like I wasn't good enough
and they were getting on me so I used
that as like motivation I'm gonna show
you so that's it's one way but it
shouldn't be your only way you know so I
was mad last one on I had a great set
come to find out that Jim Carrey and all
the producers director and writers for
the show they're scouting comics for
these parts you know so the next day I
got an audition
and then like three weeks later I was on
the show so then and that was like I'm
dying to peer we'll always have a
special place in my heart because it
like you know I had to be a real actor
on that show it was challenging to go
from like Montez being silly to have to
be like some of this character they had
like depths and emotions and he was in
Vietnam and then he had this weird
relationship with race and it was the
70s so you had to think about that and
it was I loved it so much and I'm really
sad that the show was gone the show is
gone it was cancelled and it makes me
sad I don't think so I don't think
Showtime I don't think the creators of
the show and Showtime were ever on the
same page that's my honest opinion about
it I think that they wanted something
different I think it was like Jim Carrey
and they thought it was coming but
that's to a comedy and he delivered now
two dramas I'm dying up here in kidding
and kidding is like whoa you gotta watch
kidding that [ __ ] is deep it's like he's
on a whole other thing on that one but
it was a great experience meeting Jim
Carrey and meeting all the people on
this on the crew I love everybody on
that show and I'm dying up here I love
them all gonna be some of my best
friends for life so I appreciate
appreciated that experience and so after
I'm dying up here Here I am you know I'm
traveling around the country you know
now started this podcast now we're in
with Griffin you know what I mean so if
you you know if you have a dream to be
whatever you want to be I suggest you
get off your ass and make that [ __ ]
happen I think that too many times we
become a slave to our fears
you know we're scared like why don't you
try it because you think you can't do it
well how are you gonna know unless you
try
it sounds cliche but it's so true no
matter what it is that you're trying to
do at least make an effort so you know
so you can be like you know what I tried
that damn it just didn't work out cuz
then you'll know all the reasons why it
didn't work out too and even if you
don't know those reasons even if like
you know it's like bad luck or it's like
someone was better you you put yourself
in the game and I think that's important
I always look back on my career and I'm
like damn I wish when I was 20 when
after I'd done that set it to Comedy
Store I wish I would have chased after
it way harder than I did
but things happen when they happen right
people say that I don't necessarily
believe in that I think they were just
survivors as human beings can we make
things happen because we make things
happen you know we just that's why we
can live in a cold place we can live in
a hot place because we're adaptable so
I've adapted to my situation and I tried
to catch up but I don't know you know
it's like I don't I don't have I have
regrets because I know what it could
have been I know what I should have done
and I'm and I used those regrets to make
sure that I don't make the same mistakes
so I don't always succeed but you know
I'm out here doing it man I'm trying so
we're gonna try it with this - Here I am
again late to the party again just like
my comedy career I started eight years
too late
same thing with podcasting I'm starting
hey here's to late
but who cares right we out here doing it
I'm gonna try to set up a call-in thing
where you could call and leave a message
on my website Eric Griffin calm because
hey listen I'm all about giving people
advice about the things that I've gone
through you want to talk to me about
certain things please send me messages I
want to make this better so but right
now that's just me I live in LA and I'm
gonna continue to try to do this right
now I just pitched some shows to the
network's they all said no but it was a
learning experience I learned a lot
about it so I'm gonna continue to try to
you know get back on TV cuz I love
acting a lot and I'ma continue to do
stand-up so right now I'm in Chicago I
got a show the night it's Saturday night
in Chicago in a couple weeks I'll be in
Minnesota so if you're listening to this
now you know I'll have it out before
those Minnesota dates but you can find
all my dates at Eric Griffin calm with
the K Eric Griffin calm I'm at Twitter
at Eric Griffin and you know I hope you
guys enjoyed riffing with Griffin
ristin wiig ripping ripping with
whipping